foreign
Cosmic Justice that Sam Smith and Kim
Petras perform their Satanic ritual at
the Grammys and though they they did
succeed in getting some of the attention
they crave still most of the
conversation surrounding their
performance has been focused not on the
performance but on Madonna's face the
Aging former pop star introduced the two
men on Sunday night and ever since then
people have been remarking on the fact
that Madonna looked like she was having
a potentially fatal reaction to
shellfish joke like um Marilyn Manson
reimagined as a muppet she looked like
uh she looks like she paid 15 bucks to a
caricature artist to draw a picture of
her and then brought the drawing to her
plastic surgeon and said turn me into
this
and I'm not being mean here and I'm just
trying to be precise in my description
it's important to be very precise
um and it's not my fault that Madonna
now looks like a large flightless bird
that went extinct in the pleistocene era
you can't blame me for the fact that
Madonna looks like a sock puppet she
just does
now Madonna herself seems to have
noticed the comments and the comparisons
and the fact that people are saying that
she looks like a ventriloquist dummy
from a Jeff Dunham act and so she sent
out this tweet on Tuesday
she said the world is threatened by my
power and my stem stamina my
intelligence and my will to survive but
they will never break me this is all a
test
she's right actually speaking for myself
I am blown away by her will to survive I
mean she has a net worth of only 850
million dollars after all I don't know
how she manages to endure to keep going
to survive against the odds but she does
she Wills her way through it with sheer
guts and determination and copious
amounts of Botox it is inspiring
inspiring at least to the New York Times
so while everyone else has been making
fun of Madonna the New York Times has
swooped in to explain why we should
actually admire her for destroying her
face with plastic surgery in an essay
titled Madonna's new face is a brilliant
provocation the author the author
Jennifer weiner writes quote
with blonde braids looped over her ears
dressed in a long black skirt and black
jacket accessorized with a rioting crop
one of the best female recording artists
of all time stepped into the spotlight
of the 65th annual Grammy Awards Sunday
night Madonna was there to introduce Sam
Smith and Kim Petrus a non-binary
performer and a trans woman she began by
referring to her four decades in the
music industry and praised the rebels
forging A New Path and taking the heat
for all of it
was anyone listening social media's
loudest Roars weren't about her speech
or her long time lgbtq advocacy or her
upcoming World Tour they were about
Madonna's pretty naturally smooth and
extravagantly sculpted face
all of Madonna's features looked
exaggerated pushed and Polished to an
extreme there was her forehead smooth
and gleaming as a porcelain ball Bowl
her eyebrows bleached and plucked to
near invisibility her cheekbones with
deep Hollows beneath them
people posted with a picture side by
side with that of Jigsaw from saws and
Janice from The Muppet Show and made
jokes about Desperately Seeking surgeon
while extremely online plastic surgeons
hastened to guess about exactly what
procedure she had undergone
well there's that and now comes apart
where the leftist writer does what
leftist writers love to do more than
anything which is to try to make simple
vanity seem interesting
beyond the question of what she'd done
however lay the more interesting
question of why she had done it then
Madonna get sucked so deep into the
Vortex of beauty culture that she came
out the other side had the pressure to
appear younger somehow made her think
that she ought to look like some kind of
excessively contoured baby perhaps so
but I'd like to think that our era's
greatest chameleon no a woman who has
always been intentional about her
reinvention was doing something slyer
more subversive
by serving us both a new if not
necessarily improved face and a side of
critique about the work of beauty the
inevitability of aging and the
impossible bind which older female
celebrities find themselves
people complain that she no longer looks
like like Madonna but which Madonna
comes to mind she's been a blonde and a
brunette Butch and high Femme she's worn
cast-offs and Kotor she's adopted and
abandoned an English accent she's shown
us her roots and her underwear
deliberately putting the hidden Parts on
display every new version of Madonna was
both a look and a commentary on looking
a statement about the artifice of beauty
and about her own right to set the terms
by which she was seen is it possible
that Madonna has been so blinkered by
her Fame and wealth that she's lost the
ability to see herself objectively yes
but whatever her intentions the
superstar has gotten us all talking
about how good looks are subjective and
how ageism is pervasive
in the end whether she meant to make a
statement or just to look younger better
refreshed Almost Doesn't Matter
beauty is a construct Madonna's the one
who puts it scaffolding on display
okay first of all
no
um that's not what's going on here two
points
as for beauty being a construct and
subjective
Madonna's face is actually a perfect
example demonstrating why that is not
the case
despite the extremely common
misperception beauty is not merely in
the eye of the beholder there is an
objective quality to it see everyone
agrees that Madonna's artificial face is
not beautiful everyone agrees that all
the injections and surgeries and
Plastics have not improved anything
women you know everyone knows that a
woman who ages naturally and gracefully
is more beautiful than one who
obsessively goes under the knife in a
desperate and futile attempt to reverse
the clock why do we all feel that way is
it entirely arbitrary have we settled on
this view randomly do we all happen to
have the same artificially constructive
subjective opinion about beauty
No in fact
we recognize even if we don't realize we
recognize the objective qualities of
beauty
we know even if we don't know that we
know that beauty is is wholeness
completeness
beauty is found in order in symmetry
something as beautiful if it reflects
its own Essence and if that Essence is
good
that's why a beautiful tree is one that
has grown tall and mighty not one that
is rotting and diseased and you know
covered with graffiti
Thomas Aquinas said that beauty consists
in due proportion and you know I think
this is basically what he's getting at
Madonna's fake face isn't beautiful
we all see that it isn't beautiful
because it's a rejection of what is
natural and true
it is a reflection not of her
humanness and Humanity in her Womanhood
but of her vanity and her
self-obsessions and her insecurity
there's nothing beautiful about that and
so there's nothing beautiful about her
face
truly the idea
that beauty is subjective it probably
stands alone as the one Viewpoint that
nearly everyone professes
and yet no one really believes so you
think that you think that beauty is
subjective but you don't really believe
that
and I know that you don't believe it
because here's how I know it then you
know I don't know anything about you
whoever you are listening to this
but
what I do know is that you would be
appalled
if somebody were to look out upon a
snow-capped mountain range or a lake
glistening in the sunset or someone
looked at a Rembrandt painting or who
heard a very talented choir singing
Amazing Grace and if that person
recoiled and said ew gross this is
disgusting
now you'd be you would be appalled by
someone who reacted that way you would
think that they were insane
you would not say well beauty is in the
eye of the beholder I mean that's a
perfectly valid reaction you wouldn't
now people may may resonate differently
with these sights and sounds some may be
more moved than others but no sane
person is actively repulsed by any of
those things nobody outside the walls of
an insane asylum experiences actual
revulsion at a sunset
these are Timeless and Universal
beauties
you know we're told that each culture
reinvents Beauty for itself and yet what
we actually find is that all through
history and across time in fact every
culture arrives at strikingly similar
conclusions about what is beautiful
now there may be cultures that have a
difficulty creating beautiful things our
culture for instance and cultures who
intentionally create ugly things instead
of beautiful again ours
but everybody knows what is beautiful
nobody would prefer a bathroom stall
splattered with urine stains over the
Sistine Chapel
nobody would because one is grotesque
and filthy
the other is beautiful
and we can all see that final Point
women like Madonna who refuse to age
gracefully are they are not victims of
ageism
except perhaps the ageism they direct
against themselves
really they're a reflection of a culture
that fears mortality
okay we we worship death because we we
worship youth because we are afraid of
death this is like if you want to call
it it's deathism I guess and it really
is as simple as that that's why we
worship youth because we're afraid of
death now you may think that both of
these things worshiping Youth and being
afraid of death are inevitable in every
society but you're wrong because
traditionally especially in more ancient
times the elders in a community have
been revered and respected age was
associated with wisdom
it wasn't shameful to be seen as old but
rather there was honor and dignity that
came with being of advanced age
yet these were also societies that
accepted the reality of death death was
a part of life for them they were they
were around it all the time they may
have had different ways of understanding
death different ideas about what
happened after you died but but they
didn't hide from Death itself not nearly
to the extent that we do today anyway
these days it's considered rude to even
ask somebody their age
somehow the fact that you've been
walking the Earth for more than 20 years
is supposed to be embarrassing
but why should it be why should a 65
year old woman be embarrassed that she's
65.
well for no other reason than the fact
that 65 year old women are likely closer
to death than 25 year old women and we
see age as proximity to death and death
is the one thing we don't want to be
reminded of
and so that's why we reject the aging
process entirely
indeed much of modern society is I'm
convinced fundamentally set up to
distract us from thinking about our own
deaths
but death is inevitable whether we think
about it or not
and Madonna is 64 years old whether she
Embraces that reality or not
so she might as well embrace it
there's no shame in being whatever age
you are there is only shame in being
ashamed of it
and that's why ultimately Madonna is
today canceled that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you on Friday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]